Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our fourth episode!
To explain, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
And let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
To start the day off.
We have some important news.
Important news.
Pero.
Can you help us find him, Ruffians?
Do you have any ideas where he might have gone?
Maybe he went to go train?
A tropical vacation.
Maybe he went to the casino?
Casino sounds maybe.
We didn't bully him, no!
He's in our hearts.
He's in our hearts?
That sounds really sad.
Not here on the screen.
He's there, but not like that.
Maybe he'll be with us today for when we need him in Typing for the Dead.
Let's hope.
Typing of the Dead.
I said Typing for the Dead.
Of the Dead.
He went for milk?
A secret mission.
Does Pero like milk?
I don't even know what he likes to eat.
He just has all the scraps.
Doesn't really matter.
If you see him, let us know with the hashtag FUWAMOCOMORNING.
FWMCMORNING.
Let us know where he's going if you have any... What's it?
Tips?
No tips.
Information.
Pero Sightings.
Pero Sightings, yeah.
And on more information... Yeah, from FUWAMOCO.
Directly to you.
De-den!
We have more information about Super Chibi Greetings!
We're really, really thankful for all your support.
Especially, especially during our monetization celebration stream over the weekend.
I hope, I hope it got to your heart.
We've read all of the messages that you sent us, but we're sorry that we haven't been able to read them all and properly take a moment to say thank you to you yet, but...
We'll be doing a special Super Chat Reading stream for our monetization stream and the streams following very shortly.
But starting today, we'll be beginning a Super Chat Reading segment after every stream.
Minus FUWAMOCO Mornings.
Important, important.
We feel really happy that we've been able to spend a week together and know a bit more about us, but we also feel that it's kind of unfair because we want to be able to spend more time getting to know you more closely too.
So we hope that being able to read the Super Chats and spend time chatting together every day will give us a bit more time to get to know you.
Is that okay, Ruffians?
Does that sound good?
Sounds good.
BAU BAU.
Okay.
Good!
We're looking forward to it!
Yeah!
Three hours?
Maybe not three hours.
We'll go slowly but surely.
Okay.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I think it's time for the next segment.
It's very popular, but not popular with FUWAMOCO.
Is this segment again?
There's been another misunderstanding.
First.
First, we wanted to say thank you for all your warm comments and all your thoughts that you've been tweeting about FUWAMOCO Morning on Twitter with the hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning.
Ruffians are very good.
They listen.
Yeah, they listen.
That's quite good.
Good Ruffians.
We've been really really happy that you've been enjoying this program together with us so much.
Ah, but there's one thing.
A bit of a misunderstanding.
You know, uh, we're really happy!
And we're sure that it's out of affection too, but...
FUWAMOCO Morning, FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning.
And if not, a different, a different... Like, sometimes you might be, it's a bit of a mouthful.
It's a bit of a mouthful.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight syllables.
Something like that.
So you might want to call it something shorter, but... Moco-chan, please, please don't call it...
That's embarrassing!
Please don't call us Moco.
It just sounds wrong.
Like, you know when you're getting your fur pet backwards?
We could shorten the name to like, FUWAMO!
FUWAMO!
Or like, FUWAMON!
FUWAMON!
Like Kumamon!
Shit!
You know, Ruffians, do you have any other ideas?
Yeah!
Let's hear them.
Fuwamomo?
Oh, that's cute.
But why don't you just call it Fuwamoco then?
Agumon?
That's not right.
Well, we'll all have to think together maybe.
Otherwise, Fuwamo is the decision for now.
Okay!
Okay.
Understand?
Good!
There's also another misunderstanding too!
Yesterday, while we were in Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion, you know, Fuwawa might have said something that shocked you.
But honestly, it sort of shocked her too.
It did.
You know, she got scared because she started to hear the growl sounds that Bloobs make.
Bloobs!
And a lot of the Ruffians got confused, but...
We actually realized that it makes sense that you were confused because you don't know what a Bloob is.
This is a Bloob.
We're going to introduce it to you.
It's a Bloob.
Bloobs are found in the wild.
Why are you laughing, Moco-chan?
Can you say L?
Bloobs.
Okay, introduce them.
Okay.
They're found in the Northwest Passage, and they're similar to gloobs, but they're not gloobs.
They're bloobs!
Bloobs are blue, and gloobs are green.
Yeah.
I don't know, maybe some people are more scared of the gloobs, but I don't like them.
I think bloobs are more frightening.
Sometimes you might come across a really, really big bloob inside dark light caves, so you have to be careful.
That's why huawuas are scary.
They can be pretty scary.
A bit vicious.
It looks pretty simple.
They make sort of a blub blub blub blub blub blub sound.
So you really need to use your ears to be able to look out for them.
Otherwise you know you're in for maybe a dangerous time.
I want to say that I'm sorry for raising my voice at you Ruffians.
What about me?
Mococo, you're different, you're different.
I was confused because you didn't really understand me, but now it all makes sense, you know?
Because you don't find them in the human world.
That's nice.
But yeah, there's no misunderstanding now, right?
You don't need to worry about poops, so... Good?
We're good.
Misunderstanding solved!
Thank you Moco-chan for the drawing.
You're welcome.
Can you apologize to me?
Do you hurt Moco-chan?
I hurt.
Okay, I'm sorry.
It doesn't make me feel better.
It was supposed to, I meant it.
Did you though?
Is it though?
I'm sorry for raising my voice at you and the Ruffians.
Ruffians, do you think she sounds sincere?
Huh?
I don't.
I'm sincere, though.
Yeah?
No?
Yeah!
Maybe not!
Okay.
Next!
We have something important to say.
Another confession.
So, we wanted to say, you know, there's something I think a lot of Ruffians enjoy this.
Yeah.
But actually, for FUWAMOCO, it's really embarrassing.
It's a bit embarrassing.
And it's something that we've been kind of self-conscious about for a long, long, long, long time.
Yeah.
Just sometimes.
It's actually really, really embarrassing.
Yeah, we don't want to do it.
But we just can't not do it.
Yeah, it just happens.
Right, you know?
But it's really embarrassing when we do it because it feels like we're screaming out to the world like, we're twins!
Do you understand that we're twins?
We're twins, you know?
We don't want it to be like that, you know?
You know like, when you go out and you want to get like a special puppertino, the cashier will greet you, right?
And we both say, hello BAU BAU.
And then they get all surprised and go, oh my gosh, are you two twins?
And then we say, oh yes.
And then they ask, are you identical?
You look exactly alike!
And then we say,
Yes.
So then they ask, oh, who's the older one?
Yeah, and then I have to explain that I'm the oldest, but my birthday's actually different, on a different day than Moco-chan, and then Mama Puppyhouse should work really hard, and then, you know, suddenly they know a lot about us, you know, we just wanted to slip in and order and disappear.
Yeah, just get the Puppertino and go, you know.
It's already embarrassing enough having ears and a tail.
We don't want to stand out even more.
Sometimes you just want to go, right?
But we are happy that Ruffians that you enjoy it, but for us we'd really prefer if we didn't harmonize on everything.
Do you understand?
Very relatable.
Relatable.
It's cute though.
I'm glad you find it cute though.
You know, as long as we do it that you smile a lot and maybe praise Moco-chan too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're not forgetting, right?
It'll be okay.
Maybe we won't feel so self-conscious about it.
But maybe.
We'll be counting on you, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
Got it!
I don't know, it's really weird.
It just happens.
We can't stop doing it.
I wish we could stop doing it.
Confession done!
Next!
We have something fun!
De-den!
Akihabara Mister Donut.
So you might remember, but during our Q&A stream we were asked what one of our favorite places in the world was.
And so we said that the Mister Donut location, Akihabara, is our favorite.
We've actually been receiving many many reports from the Ruffians that they've been doing Seichi Jundai, like the sacred anime pilgrimages.
Yeah!
What?
Pilgrimages!
To the Akihabara Mister Donut location.
They're having pon-de-rings too!
Our favorite!
Look look look!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for making the journey.
You know what, we've also been told that even some hololive staff members have been going and doing Seiji Junrei there too!
It's not just you, you know?
It's that great of a spot.
Everyone's taking the recommendations.
Actually, we've been seeing too that sometimes there's actually even no pon-de-rings.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So I guess for some more info, it's actually been around in Akihabara since 1972.
Yeah.
So it's been there the whole time throughout all the changes of Akihabara.
Right.
It's always there.
Akihabara's changed so much, especially recently.
Yeah!
Our favorite place.
No, we just really love this place.
So we wanted to share it with you.
Is that okay?
But our favorite order is, first you order as many pond rings as you need.
Or I guess maybe not as many as you can get.
And you get the milk tea to go with the royal milk tea.
We recommend the hot over the cold, which is actually usually the opposite.
We usually prefer the cold milk tea.
Cold milk tea is yummy, but Misudo's hot milk tea is really good.
Milk tea here actually has free refills if you ask.
Misudo.
But we recommend not doing that at the location, like Akihabara location, because it's just really small.
It's very busy.
If you go to a more faraway location, you know, sometimes the staff will even come by and ask if you want to refill in the park.
You don't even need to move.
Yeah, you can be studying and all that.
Right?
It's perfect.
Truly royal.
Yeah, and it's like, this milk tea, it's a perfect balance of bitter and strong taste.
So then when you mix it with the sweetness of the ponzu, it's just perfect.
You don't eat anything else.
Mister Donut knows his stuff.
He obviously does.
So we recommend that you try them together.
Actually, this is a bit embarrassing.
You say it.
Why do I have to say it?
It's embarrassing, so... Okay.
Ah, what's it?
Mame-tsushiki time.
Yeah.
The bean knowledge time.
Chibbit.
Yeah.
So we have actually ordered a hundred pond rings at once from this location, Akihabara, before.
And we still have the receipt up on our fridge.
It was a big deal.
Yeah, it was a big deal.
Yeah.
Yes, a hundred.
A hundred, exactly a hundred.
You had to order it well in advance.
Moco-chan, you look so happy with them though.
I was!
Right?
Look at my treasures!
Yeah, I wonder what the staff thought, huh?
They must have thought it was a big party.
Ah, maybe.
That's a bit...
But!
If you do go to the Akihabara Mister Donut, please, we recommend that you enjoy a pon-de-ring from the second floor seats if you have time.
For FUWAMOCO, we prefer the seats to the right side of the big window.
So, if you can sit there.
Extra Special.
The left side is good too, but the right side is preferred.
And most importantly... Number one, most important.
Make sure that you remember your manners, and be kind to others in the area enjoying their downtime too, okay?
No BAU BAUing too loud, okay?
You have to be a good Ruffian, okay?
Make FUWAMOCO proud.
We just really love the space.
Right?
We wanted you to love it too.
BAU BAU.
Okay, BAU BAU.
Thank you, Ruffians.
Please treat us nicely, okay?
And thank you for the pon-de-ring for two!
Thank you!
Okay, now we'll go to our regular segment.
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
It's Queenie Beanie!
She's the goobest girl ever.
Goobest.
Yeah, different from the gloobs.
Very, very different.
Gloobs don't look this cute.
Yeah, there's no green either.
No, no green.
Actually, you can tell it's the gloob.
But Queenie Beanie's a very happy girl with three paws and her barks are very loud.
Very loud.
What would it sound like, Moco-chan?
Very loud one.
Kind of loud, maybe.
Kind of loud.
Maybe like BAU BAU!
I feel like maybe it's a bit more of a cuter sound.
The tongue is good, right?
Very happy tongue.
Yeah, it kind of looks like candy, right?
And the tummy is up!
And the fashion of a bow.
Very cute.
She looks so happy.
Yeah, like she's just ready to play and play and play!
I think our rating of Queenie Beanie, you know, she never wants to leave your side.
She likes to play lots, but she also likes to cuddle too.
Definitely the coolest girl for sure.
Good ears.
She has a lot.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
For our next segment, today I went for a walk.
On a walk.
De-den!
Such a pretty scene.
Is it sunset or sunrise?
I think sunrise.
We didn't go for a walk, we went for a run!
Wow, that's impressive.
You know?
And a run with just that kind of beautiful scenery too.
And swans!
Was there anyone else around or is it just all to yourself?
I guess the swans were there.
That kind of counts.
I guess.
You know, it's really nice when you see special things like this.
Because then that just makes everything more special.
Right!
You know?
Sometimes the days can kind of feel like all the same, right?
But then, you come across something like this and you really really treasure every day you have, right?
It's also nice that even though you went running that you took a moment to enjoy all your surroundings too.
It's good to take a moment like that, right?
I'd really like to be able to go here too, so...
I hope that at least you can go and see this beautiful mirror water everyday.
Just be careful of the swans, okay?
Sometimes they can be kinda mean.
They look pretty though.
You never know with birds, okay?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day today...
Thank you for using our hashtag!
Both of you are probably the first VTubers to share a channel like this.
Are there any challenges to sharing these things?
Do you argue over what to play or anything like that?
Thank you for the question.
This is a good question.
Actually, we're not the first VTubers to share a channel.
It's Omesis and Pokopi.
But maybe we're the first VTubers who mainly do live content together, maybe?
Maybe.
But you might think there are a lot of challenges, but...
There isn't.
No.
I don't think so.
No?
No.
Yeah.
It's normal.
We don't argue over what to play.
More than anything, how we feel is like, if we play the game then that's just how we get to spend with you.
Yeah.
The game is a bonus.
You know, we just want to make you smile the most.
So... Do you argue about what you want to do?
Ruffians.
No arguments, no arguments.
No, no arguments.
Why would we argue?
Why would we have kerfuffles?
It's like... Why would we argue?
Moco-chan, I want that piece of chicken.
Can you not share?
Can you not decide on another thing?
Right?
It's not that hard.
There's lots and lots of these, right?
But yeah, I feel like the game is just a bonus to being able to be here with you.
I guess when it comes to other things, you know we split the work more or less evenly, like we do most tasks.
But this also kind of means that, I guess our skill trees can kind of get uneven.
Because like, maybe I'll do the cooking more, I'll learn more recipes, and Moco-chan will do more of the computer stuff, so then I'm better at computers and I'm not so great.
So that's not the greatest, because then I depend on you.
I can cook though.
I can.
I can unzip files, too.
I can do it.
Can you, though?
It might take me a couple minutes to panic, but I can!
Oh, but... Fuwawa's not allowed to download anything.
Okay, story time!
Story time!
Do we have time for this, Moco-chan?
One time, she downloaded something.
And for the first time,
We got a virus.
It was supposed to be just like a happy nice free font, but... No.
It caught me.
Yeah.
We aren't good at that stuff.
No.
But it's okay now, right?
It took a long time.
I was very panicked.
I'm not gonna do anything, so it's okay now.
So now she's not allowed to download things.
Yeah, I know.
But other than things like that, I guess...was that an argument?
No, that was just a panic.
That was just a panic, so that probably sounded more like Spooky's jump scare, didn't it?
Don't just let your guard down because it's a free font, okay?
Ruffians!
But yeah, I think there's a lot of Ruffians out there thinking that it must be really difficult, but really it isn't.
It's not complicated to us, you know?
We just do our thing, and we share like we've been doing our entire lives.
So don't worry.
For us there really aren't any challenges at all.
No, it's just normal.
Just normal.
It was a free font!
Yeah, gotta be careful.
We're very challenged with computers.
Anyways, we'll go to our next tier here.
De-den!
Our next tier!
We'll be back to hitting the keyboards loads today.
As we go back down to down zombies.
Back to down the zombies.
And typing from the dead.
Typing of the Dead!
I guess it'd be nice if we typed for the dead because, you know, maybe... Oh, because they can't type.
Their fingers aren't as nimble and they can't write.
Typing for the dead.
No, we're typing of the dead.
We played a bit last time.
It's a bit of a different flavour of a game.
I'm not too sure what to expect, but we're gonna hope that we can get through the rest of the game.
And maybe, what was his name?
Washington?
Washington.
G.
De-den!
You memorized it, right?
Of course.
Well, again, on Saturday we have another FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party, but this time with hololive songs only.
We just finished contacting our senpai to ask if we can sing their songs.
Guess what they said.
They all said yes!
We can sing the song!
But we were really, really nervous.
We were really, really, really nervous.
Fuwawa, is this okay?
Does this look okay?
I don't know.
It took a while.
You'd be nervous too, right?
Right.
Yeah.
Actually, some senpai said that they'd be watching too, but...
No pressure, right?
That's a lot of pressure.
Usually, we don't really practice for a karaoke, but this time, yes.
Yes.
Practice.
We'll do our best.
But more than anything, have fun.
Fun.
We'll also be appearing on Kyoto Senpai's Holotalk earlier that day.
And this is going to be our first collab with Senpai.
I guess all of Abyss will be there too, but
We'll also be playing Sakura Wars 5 for the first time on Sunday, but we have a good question.
We have the choice of playing it with the Japanese dub or the English dub.
Japanese dub or English dub?
JP dub!
Maybe we'll make a poll on Twitter, too.
On Twitter, maybe YouTube, too.
And then we can figure it all together.
JP Dub.
I see a lot of JP Dub.
Just to make sure, we'll make one on Twitter, okay?
Just one.
In my inside, I prefer English.
Well, you know, there's some Ruffians that like to listen along.
Yeah, right.
While you're working, or...
I'm excited.
There's so much to look forward to.
And for FUWAMOCO Morning today, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruviewers today.
Ruviewers?
Ruviewers!
Cuppy Dog City!
BAU BAU!
We hope you enjoyed your breakfast!
ZigZag!
BAU BAU!
Moomba!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!